[Music]
hello everyone my name is nathan morty
so i'm one of the group product managers
in data analytics space you guys have
seen me on the keynote demo there but if
you have not i'm gonna show you what
data fusion is all about so before I get
started I wanted to give you guys enough
context of where it's being used I
wanted to introduce my colleague Robert
here who's from tellus digital so he's
going to basically give you guys the
context in terms of how they are looking
to use data fusion so with that I will
have it over to Robert see you guys in a
few minutes and thank you everyone hi so
I'm Robert I'm a Software Architect with
Telus digital if you're not familiar
with Telus it's a Canadian
telecommunications firm that operates in
the traditional telecom verticals we
offer the phone internet mobile phone
television services and won't surprise
you to learn that in the course of
conducting our business we collect a
very large amount and we generate a very
large amount of data that we need to
carefully and responsibly manage that
data it also needs to be sifted for
whatever insights we can glean in order
to better serve our customers so we're a
growing business and we're moving into
new lines of business all the time some
of those areas come replete with their
own data specific challenges in some
instances we're confronted with a
particular security strictness that we
have to contend with in other areas we
have compliance and regulatory regimes
that we have to deal with in still other
areas we have particular data volume and
velocity challenges that we need to
contend with so all of this is to say
that over the course of 100-year history
and a number of mergers and acquisitions
where every new member of the family has
come with new data standards new data
processes systems our landscape has
grown extremely complex this complexity
has been very hard to contend with you
know it's hard just to grapple with it
to grok it to understand it let alone to
try and merge it all or fuse it into a
unified whole so to try and to
understand where some of the places we
were falling short are we recently
conducted a survey of all
participants in our data ecosystem from
which we learned that the average score
people were willing to give to our data
and our data systems was a rather
middling 2.74 on a five-point scale not
as good as it could be unfortunately the
data that we received was rich enough to
reveal an interesting pattern which was
that the closer you are to generating
data particularly if you're a human that
only deals with a single database or a
single data generating process the
happier you intended to be with your lot
in life if you're a person that was
responsible for taking data and
transforming it somehow relocating it or
handing it off you were generally a
little less content with your lot and if
you were a downstream consumer of data
you were generally somewhat unhappy this
is particularly if you needed to rely on
a synthesis of data across functional
data from a lot of different upstream
data sources so generally speaking the
picture was that the higher you went in
the organization and the more data you
had to touch the more unhappy you were
and since that describes senior-level
decision makers we realized that we had
a bit of a problem that we had to solve
the implication for what for us was that
we needed to walk before we could run
we're very interested in exploring some
sophisticated capabilities like machine
learning we wanted to build out an AI
program but we realized that before we
could do any of that we needed to fix
our data problems so the answer for us
was to explore the principles of supply
chain management and to undertake a data
supply chain program so building a data
supply chain is replete with many
challenges those challenges include the
need to integrate data from a great
number of sources integrating meaning
clean validate refined reconcile data
through an often complex chain of
lengthy transformations we also have to
handle the entire data lifecycle our
data is born it lives and is an active
use and it retires and eventually
becomes obsolete and during the entire
course of this events we need to avoid
breakage we need to provide a consistent
and canonical view of data to our users
and in particular we want to compute key
business metrics just once and in just
one way if possible we needed to better
understand our data we need an ontology
to obscure i'b share meaning to data and
in particular we needed comprehensive
metadata and lineage information about
all of our data down to the field level
for every field we wanted to build a
unitary system something that supported
many roles from less to more technical
without causing an explosion in the
number of tools that we had to build
their support and we wanted something
that was ubiquitous something that lived
in all the places where our data lived
and made data location transparency
pivotal ultimately we needed safe and
secure delivery of our data to our
downstream consumers we wanted to break
out of all the data data silos that
existed in the enterprise all of this
has to happen in the context of a world
where cloud is an important part of what
we do and we've learned that building
hybrid cloud architectures is
challenging some of those challenges
include the need for portability we need
to build things locally develop Artic
artifacts that we can run locally but
also run on Prem and our data like for
example as well as to moving into the
cloud for scaling and other benefits
that cloud offers we need to be able to
distribute our data pipelines so they
seamlessly bridge from on Prem to cloud
so that our data can flow back and forth
without any friction we need
extensibility so we need standard hooks
well-defined places to add our own
business logic to add data
transformations to add connectors to
various data sources
ideally without bespoke integration
every bit of bespoke code that we have
to write to support these things means
an additional burden in terms of
technical debt that we'd rather avoid we
have the problem of affinity some
applications just resist hybridization
some datasets have to be pinned to a
certain location for various reasons
conversely some data has to be
duplicated and that comes with its
attendant challenges of having a unified
view of your data maintaining data
lineage and so on and the problem of
testability is key in in as much as
things vary from environment to
environment we want to isolate those
things test them once we want to test
once not test once per environment right
and we want sufficient abstraction that
we can build our pipelines build our
data transformations build our logic
test it once and know that it's going to
run in all the places where we needed to
so taking GCP is our example of a single
cloud or here why not we realize that we
suffer from an embarrassment of riches
the great number of services on offer
mean that we are faced with the service
integration challenges we're faced with
a fairly steep learning curve building
even a relatively simple pipeline you
know imagine landing data and GCS
modifying it with data proc pushing it
into bigquery or BigTable and ultimately
surfacing it in data studio you know
recall what it was like to be a newbie
to the platform and how daunting all of
those things seemed and then imagine
having to stitch them all together right
this is something that we needed to come
up with a way to address you know all of
this impacts our speed to productivity
you know the more things that we're
touching and trying to stitch together
the greater our challenge we want to
find a way to make easy things easy in
spite of the fact that digging into
specific tools yields benefits you know
greater performance lower cost we still
need a way to tie things together
without having to be deep experts in
every single part of the data pipelines
that we build so multi-cloud we live in
a multi cloud world and there's no
escaping it you know this comes with a
challenge of finding people that are
sufficiently skilled you know finding
folks that are knowledgeable about one
cloud platform is hard finding unicorns
that know and have deep expertise across
multiple clouds is you know
correspondingly more difficult when
things inevitably go wrong finding the
root cause of the problems has made much
more complicated when your applications
are parceled out across multiple clouds
you know and with the greater mix of
tools and services available across
clouds you'll find that you know finding
the right mix of things for to tailor
for precisely your application is more
difficult and of course there may come a
time when you want to move on to or off
of a particular cloud and to the extent
that you've tailored your applications
to the interfaces of those cloud you'll
find that you have a higher switching
cost to pay so the question before us is
can we find or build a tool to tie a
broad array of services together near
seamlessly across our on-prem and cloud
infrastructure Multi cloud
infrastructure in fact in a way that
minimizes the cognitive load of taking
advantage of all this power we want a
platform that supports the end
data lifecycle something that helps us
manage data from the moment of its
capture till its eventual eventual
retirement we want something that helps
us better understand our data and
processes something that explains the
origin and the lineage of all the data
that flows through the system we want
something that supports a broad mix of
less technical and more technical users
giving all of these folks at home
there's something within which they can
easily access the data that they need
and build flows to shape it in the way
that they want and to add on a few extra
bullet points if we could find something
that was open source and that has a
community so much the better if we can
find something that we know scales from
micro jobs all the way up to massive and
if we could find something that's
sufficiently flexible that we can mold
and shape it to our needs we'd be that
much happier so about a year ago I was
introduced to something called seed app
the seed app was an open-source tool for
big data processing and having dug into
it I became very excited it seemed to
address a lot of these points that I've
mentioned and it wasn't so long after
first encountering the tool and getting
excited I learned that it had joined the
Google cloud family of services and had
become what you're going to hear about
today data fusion
since then the I diffusion has become an
important part of our data integration
efforts as we move in our data supply
chain into a hybrid and multi cloud
world and data fusion solves a number of
the pain points that we suffer and I'd
like to introduce Nitin to tell you a
little bit more about it thank you thank
you Robert
thank you so so let's talk about
diffusion diffusion what is data fusion
so data fusion is a fully managed cloud
native data integration service it's
basically helping you to efficiently
build and manage data pipelines with the
graphical interface and a broad
collection of open source
transformations and hundreds of other
box connectors it helps you it helps
organizations shift the focus from code
and integration to insights and actions
it's actually built on and opens open
source
nology called sadef sadef has been in
existence for quite some time now this
is a managed worsen of it so we can talk
more about sita in general but sedap has
as a platform allows you to build data
analytical applications and as part of
their analytical applications there are
a few analytical applications that are
also included as part of seed app and
one of them is ability to build data
pipelines the second one is more about
how do you transform the data without
having to write any code that we call
them regular data prep the name has been
constantly changing but it's an ability
where if you are specifying
transformations you're applying data
quality checks you don't need to be
writing any code and that is another
accelerator or an application that is
built on top of Sita
so we basically there are more other
things like that like rules engine a
bunch of things like that which we will
look at it later but what we have done
now is taken those two parts with
ability to build pipelines and every
ability to do transformations without
having to write code and along with the
Sita platform we have turned that into a
managed offering on TCP so when you look
at the kinds of use cases that you can
use to solve this and the problems that
it is trying to address first things
that it is trying to address like Robert
mentioned it's making it extremely easy
to move data around right so right now
if you are doing it all by yourself
it's it's very error-prone it's very
time consuming so if I have to write
move data from let's say GCS to bigquery
I would have to spend a lot of time
writing code and ensuring that that code
actually works every single time and
that's not to say if I have to do
another such point-a to point-b
transition with added transformation I
start all over again so essentially at
the end of it it increases your TCO
right so just for moving you're spending
way too much time and then you're
actually getting into situations where
you might not be able to address all of
the business requirements that you have
right and also skills gap is another
thing so it's like you need to have
right set of skills and have good
expertise in the systems that you're
stitching them together right because
there are performance requirements there
are a bunch of things related to how
those best practices you need to be
adhering to so all that is kind of very
difficult right and the last one is
hybrid and hybrid is something that is
very interesting actually during our
process through EAP which is the early
access program on GCP we learned that
actual journey to cloud starts on tram
it's not like lift and shift and
everything is done is it's kind of hard
you need to be able to start your
journey slowly from an on-trend
environment so just by the combination
of seed app and data fusion it allows
you to do so and you don't need to build
it twice you can build it once and be
able to run them in two different
environments so who are who are the
users that we are targeting with data
fusion right so we are leveling it we
are moving the level up in terms of
being able to adapt adopt GCP and being
able to apply transformations when you
look at when there is a need for
developer data scientist or business
analyst to cleanse transform blend
transfer data or standardize
canonicalize automate your data
operations develops we want you to be
using data fusion data fusion provides a
graphical interface with that it also
provides ability for you to test debug
as well as deploy you can deploy that
scale on GCP and there we can
essentially scale to your data levels
right so it's essentially can scale to
petabytes of data there now in addition
to that we also collect a lot of
metadata whether it is business
technical or operational all of this
metadata is aggregated within data
fusion and we are going to be we are
exposing that in terms of lineage so you
will be able to do things like a root
cause analysis impact analysis be able
to find provenance right be able to
associate a lot of metadata for the data
pipelines that you are building as well
as datasets that you are creating with
it and that's a very important part of
having data operations anywhere so when
you look at
the kinds of use cases that diffusion is
trying to solve right diffusion these
are different business imperatives that
translate into IT initiatives and maps
to how the diffusion can help solve so
when you are looking to build warehouses
you're actually trying to get data from
many different sources let's say into
bigquery as an example you should you
should make it extremely easy to do that
it should not take you years six months
not not that long you should be able to
operationalize these things pretty
quickly when you are actually looking to
my retire legacy systems diffusion can
help you migrate that data over to GCP
it doesn't it doesn't need to be just
bigquery you can put it in spanner you
can put it in cloud sequel datastore
BigTable you can pretty much be able to
connect to anything that is available on
GCP to bring that data in and it's not
just limited from a sources perspective
to on trim you can also read from the
same set of sources that you have
written to in GCP data consolidation is
another aspect so you're trying to
either migrate some data or essentially
delete or essentially retire a bunch of
data that exists there master data
management is something that has a bunch
of capabilities but we are going to be
adding a lot more in this year to
essentially help create a much more
consistent high-quality environment for
your data and the last one is extend or
migrate in cases on a hybrid environment
where you want to you know load shared
into cloud if you are still on prem you
will be able to do those kinds of things
the thing is the complexity of it being
able to run on cloud on pram and in
other clouds that's the biggest part of
all this you should be able to run that
across anywhere so just to put it all
together so the way I like to think
about this is data fusion is providing a
fabric which allows you to fuse a lot of
different technologies and products that
are available on GCP in a much more easy
accessible secure performant and into
manners it just makes the entire process
extremely easy so the things that would
take me six weeks to build I can
literally build them in two minutes
deploy them in on the third minute and
be able to operationalize operational I
should not be that easy but like it
takes let's say a day or so right so
basically this is bringing a lot of
different things together making it
extra simple it's it's moving up the
moving up the bar lowering the barrier
to entry
essentially for GCP when you talk in
terms of data so with that brief
introduction I'm going to show you guys
a demo of data fusion
so let's get started so data fusion as I
said is a is a managed offering so it
will it would be available through cloud
console so you will be starting today
you will be able to see data fusion show
up on the cloud console so now what we
have done is we have basically taken
data fusion and given two different
editions they we have made two different
editions available to you all what is
the basic Edition the second one is an
Enterprise Edition you should be able to
pick depending on your needs and we
recommend basic edition to be more for
their I would say not so highly
available QA environment but Enterprise
Edition is more for like you know
mission-critical stuff so you should be
able to provision off of those two
editions to start that so here I have
already created a few of them I mean
these are all you can see these are next
demo stuff so a bunch of different
things that have been created and all
our enterprise but I can go into create
instance and be able to specify and here
are the regions that we are here of the
zones and locations that we are starting
with so we have Asia East Europe West
Central East and West all of these so as
we go along we'll be adding more
locations in this year so once I create
the instance I can jump into data fusion
entirely so this is data fusion it looks
a lot like a cockpit where essentially
you have a lot of things that you have
interacted with this is called the
control center control center is the
place where you are actually able to
monitor and be able to manage all of
your data sets and data pipelines this
is a central place for doing that so you
also have an ability to you know work
with the pipelines this is the list of
explicit pipelines that you are
interested in here we have put a few
pipelines that have been scheduled to
run and they have been running
additionally you also have a studio
where you can build different pipelines
it's a visual way of building all of
these pipelines being able to deploy
them and also we have a place where we
are collecting metadata
I skipped on one Wrangler I'll come back
to that this is where we are collecting
all of the pipeline metadata as well as
all of the different data center data it
gets collected here so the interesting
part now let's imagine you have data
sitting in in an Oracle system right
it's like it's an on trend Oracle system
and you want to bring data in its you're
not just limited to Oracle actually you
we have hundreds of auto box connectors
that allow you to connect to various
systems starting from mainframe to being
able to connect to a bunch of different
cloud sources right so in order to do
start this so we have started providing
a very simple way of bringing data in
right so first thing you're seeing here
is I have pulled in a data from an
Oracle table now let's see how did we
get here right so track letter allows
you to collect to connect to various
different data sources these are the
popular ones we are going to be adding a
lot more in in in coming months actually
so I have already pre-configured an
oracle table here I can actually add
more databases databases that can
support JDBC can be easily added here we
are also support Kafka as three GCS big
query answer so as soon as your instance
gets created it automatically attaches
to your projects GCS big query and
spanner so now let's say I have data
sitting in Oracle here so this is now
live listing all of the Oracle tables
and I'm interested in bringing in one
table only not to say we have ability to
also bring the entire database over so
you don't have to do one table at a time
you can bring the entire database over
so let me click on the employees table
as soon as I click the data gets there
are many different ways the data can be
sample but the data get sample all of
the the the data types of the source
data system gets translated into an
intermediate which we
essentially it's Avro where it gets
translated into Avro types so it's
basically an Avro spec but it is an
extended have respect to specify various
other types so now once I'm here I can
apply transformations so now the first
thing I see is commission commission
percentage is being highlighted for like
there's some data that's actually
missing here now enough for order to
process I want to make sure I can
specify some you know default values so
I'm gonna fill 0.0 here to the
Commission there's zero percent
commission I can now see it's hundred
percent complete right I can also see
that the job ID is a combination of two
things Department and title so I want to
be able to specify a way to split those
so I can go in here
I say extract fields so now we generated
two columns right Sarah I don't need
this specific column from here and I'm
good right so now but you want to get a
little bit insight of how your data is
organized so we basically make it easy
for look at you to get a little bit of
insight on your data so there is a very
very can essentially slice and dice this
data in and have a visual way of looking
at how the different dimensions are
organized dominative data records so for
a certain type so you can do drill down
on these and look at and compare that
with other dimensions right so this is
just to give you a feel of how your data
that you have pulled in is or the sample
that you have been for is organized so
once we are comfortable with this I will
say go create a pipeline because my
source right now is Oracle I this it's
not a real-time source right so it's a
bad source right now because we are
pulling it in batch but you can also do
a real-time data pull from Oracle so
like if you are doing things like CDC
and such so I want to create a batch
pipeline so what that does is it
transfers all the work that I did in
Wrangler into my studio where I can
author the rest of the pipeline my goal
was to get those transformation now I
started with Wrangler to create this but
he can go the other way too you can
actually go
being in this canvas or a studio to
being able to wrangle that so it's just
by dropping one of the transforms like
triangular transforms here you should be
able to do that seamlessly for
simplicity I'm just using a very simple
pipeline so if you then you want to be
able to let's say you want
now this is not opera this is not going
to be operating on just the sample it's
going to be operating on the entire
table that you're trying to pull so then
I can go ahead and you know figure out
like I need to put this into let's say
bigquery for analytics I also want to
make sure that I can actually store this
data or archive this data into GCS right
so it's as easy as that
now I give it I can figure these
configurations are also pretty easy here
so you just define the configuration
which is you know your data set your
table name that's all you need to
specify those are the mandatory fields
your done
that's how you essentially bring data
into bigquery the same holds true for
GCS perspective you specify how your
bucket needs to be there what is your
suffix path is and you can also define
the format in which you want to write
that data in it's not limited to it so
now the Wrangler that I specified there
that I showed you guys there were more
than thousand plus functions which
include a lot of data quality checks
which I'm going to show you guys but the
most important thing with that is it is
extendable you can write your own data
transformation we call them directives
you can write your own data
transformation directives and you can
just drop them in and use them in any
pipeline right that gives you share
ability so to show that let me see after
doing this I feel like oh man I missed
something so I want to go back and do
more operations here right so I want to
be able to say like I said things like
for example this employee ID changed my
type - let's say long so I should be
able to do those types of things so I go
back and I make those transformations
and I'm
and done with it so let's see I go back
okay so all of the transformations are
here so now whatever I have done can be
configured so right now the pipeline we
provide two different ways of being able
to execute the pipeline you can run them
as a spark job you can run them as a
MapReduce job but we are also going to
be in future adding an ability to for
you to run that as a dataflow job so you
build a pipeline you'll be able to run
in any of these three things without
having to make any change to your
business logic let that sink in for a
bit you then have an ability to specify
resources so like this this is actually
for MapReduce okay that's not that
interesting it's a old one so let's go
of it sparks so you can change how spark
behaves so you can specify
configurations you can specify very
specific and we don't recommend actually
for you to do this I'm just showing you
that these are available if you guys are
interested in fine tuning your
particular pipeline we also do support
alerts so again these alerts again these
are we do provide a developer SDK that
allows you to extend these and add your
own thing for example one of our users
actually wrote a slack connector so
every time a pipeline finishes it sends
a slack message I think there was one
someone wrote a HipChat
one and there was Twilio one like a
bunch of things like that so you can
make the notifications pretty pretty
easy with these so in addition to this
you also have the ability to schedule
your pipelines from here you can define
them here or you can define them once
they are deployed now the interesting
thing here is you can actually debug the
pipeline as soon as you go into the
preview mode it provides you an ability
to test your pipeline and it actually is
going to go to the original source bring
that data in so right now it supports n
number you n is default or 200 rows but
if you want to run another larger sample
you should be able to do that it just
takes a little bit more time when you
are looking to preview terabytes of data
but we are looking to improve that and
essentially be able to do this
constantly in real time so that you can
look at the data as your
the pipeline so all of this actually
translates one question that I always
get asked is is this generating a spark
or MapReduce code and it's is it is it a
code generator and my answer to that is
no it's not a code generator then I
don't know how many of you guys know but
this is the word that was coined long
time ago called code weaving so it
weaves all of the different components
that are being built for one execution
engine in an optimized way so there is
actually a planner that picks up all the
bits and pieces and translates that into
an execution plan so it weaves all of
the stuff that we're built into a pack
and it figures out what is the optimal
way of transferring the data from one
node to the other in most cases it's
amazing because you're not going from
one machine to the other you in most
cases you are actually doing in memory
transfers and that's how it gets
composed into the execution paradigm and
that's the same thing we can do for
running it in SPARC we can do the same
thing for running it in
MapReduce and that the ability for us to
be able to push down some of those
optimizations or basically leverage the
optimizations that are available in the
underlying system is extremely critical
and we are able to do that without
having to make major architectural
changes to this now once a pipeline is
built you can actually see it generates
a configuration right it's a simple JSON
configuration you can build it all by
yourself by it with Han it's not very
complicated it has just a few sections
and for everything there in addition to
defer being able to define the graphs it
actually tracks every individual nodes
the artifact version so you can
essentially track every component that
is being used is being worshipped
actually so you're able to version every
part of it so if you come up with the
new way of connector or updated if there
was a bug and you fixed it you should be
able to use that seamlessly and the
system allows you to migrate from
version to version B making sure all of
those checks have been handled carefully
so with that this is this is essentially
an ability to build a batch pipeline but
he can also do the same thing with
real-time pipelines actually so you can
build a bunch of real-time pipelines
looks like there are a few there not
that many plugins available here but
that's the reason we have added hub so
how is a place where you can we will be
adding more connectors more
transformations more reusable components
here that will make will be making it
available here and the best part is you
can have your own in organizational
internal hub so you can share some of
the connectors or plugins that you're
doing with extra within with other users
within your organization it makes it
extremely easy for you to do that it's a
spec that we are ask you it's actually
documented SPAC so if you can follow
that spec you can get in exactly the
same market for your organization in
addition to what we do provide and here
where we put stuff these are a lot of
things that we have built over the years
over the period of seven years but we
are also getting a lot of contributions
from within Google our open source
community as well as we are working with
lot of partners to be able to build this
and the one important distinction that
we are making right when I talk about
data fusion data fusion is actually not
is unlimited user every instance there
is no limit on number of users who can
access it that's number one between
basic and enterprise we are not
distinguishing connectors every single
connector will be available in both of
them right unlike the when you look at
like how we essentially do connectors
generally we didn't want it to keep that
choy give that choice is essentially we
wanted to keep it plain and simple so
every connector would be available of
the things that we build so from here
you want db2 plugin you can just deploy
it it gets added to your instance that's
it with that you are now able to use the
db2 connect a db2 plug-in to talk to db2
instances so the same thing holds true
so there are lot of different real time
connectors that are available transforms
get shared analytics of different kinds
where your
you're actually doing joins or you're
actually aggregating data you're
profiling data all that stuff is readily
available and the real-time pipelines
actually right now when they run in GCP
they're on a spark streaming pipelines
okay with that let me show you a little
bit of a few things that you can do with
this so this is a very simple example of
a pipeline that was deployed here where
you're essentially taking data from
various different sources joining them
together and writing it into bigquery
this pipeline has been I think has been
scheduled to run you get operational
metrics on this pipeline you're able to
see how this pipeline is behaving over a
period of time all of this data that I
am showing you all of the stuff that I
just did in from sorry from the UI you
should you are able to do those using
REST API so every single aspect of this
is available through publicly available
REST API so if you're looking for
something on this dashboard it's
actually available as a REST API for you
to pull so that you can integrate with
your internal systems if you would like
to so now if you see here what's
happening is when you ran this pipeline
actually this pipeline is using a data
prop profile that's automatically
created for you so there is this notion
of provisional and profiles and profiles
are based off of provisioners so here is
a profile that I have but the system
automatically creates for you and you
can see using this profile all the
different pipelines that are being
executed and how much time they take
from an execution perspective so you can
define different profiles for different
kinds of workloads you know if you're
doing large migration you want to be
able to say that you're doing heavy ETL
transformations you should be able to
specify a profile for that so something
that can be controlled by administrators
but also if needed you the users
themselves can change them if they have
the right permissions
so you have also the ability to look at
every run of the pipeline so this is
just one execution of the pipeline so I
can go back in time so we do keep for a
long periods of time all of this data in
in Indy diffusion and one one important
thing so like this pipeline could be
scheduled right this pipeline also can
be triggered by the execution actions
that are generated from the previous
pipeline right so I can say to trigger
this run of the pipeline only when the
previous pipeline successfully completes
or it has just completed or it has
failed then trigger it so you have an
ability to do that and when you talk
about different use cases where you're
looking at many different teams involved
in building a much larger pipeline which
is organization wide where there's a
team a responsible for bringing data in
from external sources sanitizing them
landing it in a staging area and then
from their analytics team picks that
data and runs their analytics and or
essentially do some aggregations and
write them into B Q and that the team
could be taking it from there right so
now the thing is information needs to be
passed from one execution of one
pipeline to the other so for example
where you're landing on the staging area
so with tokens that are being passed
between these pipelines you are able to
do that and you can pick and choose
whether witch tokens you want to pass
I'm in this example you have plugins you
can pass the runtime arguments you can
pass you can even pass compute configs
in there so this is just a simple
example of where you are doing all of
the different joints they can be far
more complex pipelines you can build so
I want to show you guys one other
pipeline so this is a real-time pipeline
which is not running it should be
running so this is a very simple
real-time pipeline which actually is
taking data from is watching for data
that is that is arriving on GCS as soon
as the data arrives it parses cleanses
the data sends it to sense it to data
profiling it profiles that data for that
window whatever you have specified right
like if I specify a 15 minute or an hour
data that's coming in profile that and
that profile information is
actually written to pops up now all the
good data gets written to bigquery and
any of the errors that are generated in
the records are because of any bad data
actually gets separated out and gets
written into GCS so this is all is a
real time for play and of course it's
it's it's a micro batch but when we do
integrate this with dataflow you will
have true streaming capability and you
will still be able to do this kind of
stuff so very simple things this is this
is how we are taking it to the next
level so this is an example of mini when
a use case where you want to move the
data but you you have no idea of the
risk profile of that data and you want
to be able to make sure that if there is
any sensitive data you want to exclude
that out before you send it to let's say
your final data store right so this is
this is something that we are going to
be making it available soon in q2 which
is the integration with DLP so if I want
to integrate with DLP it's just drag DLP
and put it in there configure it your
DLP work is done right now you might say
how do we ensure that every data set
that I have needs to be always be passed
through DLP so think of those two nodes
and you are essentially creating
different kinds of data sets right like
for example this is a GCS one that's
being sent to let's say DLP so you can
you will have the ability to create
templates you will take GCS and you will
take DLP and you create a template out
of that and what that will allow you to
do is essentially be able to anytime
anyone uses that it will always be
applying DLP transformations on that or
DLP filtering or tokenization zhan that
so that is much more an easier way for
you to club things this is a very filter
example the filter example is actually
allowing you
to only filter/data but we'll be adding
more capabilities in terms of being able
to tokenize fields and such so you'll
have ability to you know right now you
say you know with some confidence
interval which is like in a filter
confidence is low any any time when
there is credit card numbers that gets
identified as sensitive data filter it
out so I can pick and choose a bunch of
different things I will be soon be able
to also tokenized an and clip them a
bunch of things like that so so this is
all great so this is all about building
the pipelines I showed you guys how you
can operationalize them what are the
metrics that are available logs are also
similarly available in the same fashion
but the most important thing from an
operational perspective is can we
actually monitor all of the pipeline's
in one place so you have an ability to
monitor and there are more things that
would be enabled as soon is this is
actually looking at all of the pipelines
that are running and an hour-by-hour and
you will be able to look at each
individual pipeline and how they were
being executed what was their like you
know what time did it take in fact we
also include things like start delays so
what ends up happening is we had a lot
of customers who scheduled the pipeline
actually to be running at like let's say
at 2:00 a.m. in the morning because it
happens all independent of each other
the capacity within that project gets
hit because everything starts around at
the same time right so how do you avoid
that so this has a little bit of a
futuristic view one - it also gives you
an idea of how much time it is taking to
start something up because the resources
are not available so you can actually go
into future and look at what are the
different jobs that are being scheduled
at every hour and what does that mean
from a capacity perspective to be able
to run that clip in that hour so you get
a visibility into those kind of things
which makes it extremely easy for from
an Operations perspective so one last
thing before we go into Q&A session is
the metadata that we talked about so I
can search this is all in the context of
integration right so this is all in
context of integrate
you guys will have lots of questions
around how does this integrate the data
catalog so let me give you an answer
before you ask but the whole idea here
is we are both are a beta product right
now but at some point we would be making
a read-only version of all of this
metadata available in data catalog
number one number two will still
continue enhancing the experiences of of
solving the problems from a data
integration perspective in data fusion
so that will still remain here so things
like deep lineage field level lineage a
bunch of things that are very very
relevant to integration would still be
available in here so this is the data
set that I was looking at that was the
joint pipeline and I was I can see the
schema here the attached bid net
business tags so this is like you know I
don't know I'm just going to say double
click here so I should be able to
immediately search based on that you can
look at seen lineage at a data set level
but the interesting is you can look at
lineage at a individual field level so
you're able to actually figure out what
happens to individual fields when the
data is being ingested so for example if
I'm looking at a landing page URL this
actually comes from a landing page data
set if I'm looking for referral URL it's
coming from impression data say if I'm
looking at advertiser field it's coming
from an advertiser data set but the
interesting thing is what are the
operations that were being applied as
the data was being moved it went through
different joints it was read from this
source so there our goal is to be able
to write this in a normal like like an
English text so you can just read this
to be able to see how your data is
actually going to be moving that is the
goal and we have started basically
starting to do that but the this is a
long way to go in in terms of making it
full English tax so that you can just
read it but you will have it you'll get
an idea of what we are where we are
going with this so just being able to
look at where the data has come from and
where it is going to go gives you a lot
of flexibility to do that
[Music]